Peter Brown here with another GameSpot
news update the NPD numbers are out for
June and what do you know the Xbox one
sold twice as many systems as it did in
May but despite that the PlayStation 4
was still the best-selling console the
NPD group has released their monthly
sales figures and the respective console
manufacturers have released statements
based on the report microsoft announced
that Xbox one sales had more than
doubled from May to June after its
connect list four hundred dollar model
went on sale later sony said in a
statement that the playstation 4 came
out on top in the US during june noting
that this is the sixth month in a row
that the playstation 4 has been the top
seller sony also said that the
playstation 4 was a top platform for
physical software sales among the new
generation of consoles sales of the Wii
U continue to rise thanks to the launch
of Mario Kart 8 compared to June of 2013
wii u sales are up two hundred and
thirty-three percent 3ds sales are up
fifty-five percent over May but the NPD
group noted that there was a
year-over-year decline in portable
hardware sales compared to June of last
year though hardware sales are up 106
percent bringing in 290 2.7 million
dollars this year compared to 142
million dollars this time last year as
far as software goes wash dogs is the
overall highest seller win counting all
five of its platforms while Mario Kart 8
was the number one when comparing
individual products brawl your video
game and number related news stay tuned
to gamespot com